c'est un homme une autre chronique
épique maintenant c'est celles
qu'entretient tous les jours ici même le
procureur général de la république des
proches française
[Musique]
oh
non
comment françaises français belges belge
monsieur le président monsieur bruno
lazare monsieur gare saint bruno pardon
monsieur bruno garcin reçu le rigolo
monsieur rigolo détourneurs de mineurs
mesdames et messieurs les jurés public
chéri mon amour jamais autant
qu'aujourd'hui monsieur le président
mesdames et messieurs les jurés jamais
la tâche noble est rude que m'a confié
la république en mai drapant dans la
robe austère de la justice sous laquelle
vivre un coeur gros comme ça
attention c'est là qu'elle vibre un
coeur gros comme ça voir figure 1
jamais autant qu'aujourd'hui mesdames et
messieurs les jurés cette tâche ne m'a
paru plus difficile plus lourde plus
plus âpre plus énorme
voici un homme qui fait rire les enfants
depuis 50 ans et vous me demandez de
l'envoyer à la guillotine c'est dur
c'est très dur comme disait guy lux à
qui l'on demandait quel était le pluriel
du mot cheval c'est très très très dur
de même que thierry le luron un autre
ami des enfants s'appellent vraiment le
luron achille zavatta s'appelle vraiment
zavatta c'est son vrai nom
les parents de cet homme aux mises au
monde en lui donnant un vrai nom de
clown c'est tout à fait incroyable
il ya des jours comme ça si on se rate
n'est pas on se prendrait est à croire
en dieu
alors que jean edern [ __ ] lui il a
été obligé à prendre un pseudonyme
décidément les desseins du seigneur sont
vraiment impénétrables il n'y a pas que
d'ailleurs
jeanne d'arc elle même était
impénétrable le resta jusqu'à ce qu'elle
nie c'était ce qu'elle meure cuites mais
qui l'eût cru c'est le réseau de la
défense devrait confirmer comment faire
comment faire quels arguments trouvé
pour envoyer zavatta aux bourreaux non
mais regardez le mesdames et messieurs
les jurés regardez le il a autour des
yeux ces petites rides de joie qui sont
l'empreinte même des rires de cristal
qu'il a fait jaillir par milliers du
coeur des enfants du monde
ah non monsieur le président excusez-moi
suis ému je ne puis assumer ma tâche
aujourd'hui je ne peux pas je
préférerais encore vous rendre non pas
mon tablier mais ma robe
cette robe austère voulez vous que je
vous la rendre voulez vous que je lui
ôte tout de suite leur roster
y at il des habilleuses dans la salle
hilare links où finalement ce qui nous
émeut chez agatha
ce n'est pas lui ce sont les enfants les
enfants qui lui sert tout à la fois
d'alibi et de circonstances atténuantes
avec leurs culottes courtes et leurs
petites joues roses mais je vous le
demande mesdames et messieurs les jurés
les enfants sont ils vraiment innocent
ewc fiel zh oui je dirais monsieur le
président je dirais d'abord youssif is
le jour les américains diront champs
elysées au lieu de dire 110w ses filles
elle se disait quelqu'un qui n'aime pas
les enfants ne peut pas être tout à fait
mauvais je ne sais pas si monsieur fiel
la raison tout ce que je sais c'est que
le bon dieu l'a puni en lui donnant un
prénom tiote c'est bien fait pour ça
et d'abord d'abord qu'est ce qu'un
enfant
comment reconnaître un enfant d'un
adulte à part la taille d'autant que la
taille est un indice et non point est
une preuve
ainsi que le faisait remarquer le nain
pyrale au gorille du porno palace qui
lui donnait une fessée pendant
l'entracte de sa glisse au pays des
merveilles c'est sur le poupe
c'est sur le plan purement psychologique
que nous devons nous situer pour pouvoir
reconnaître un enfant d'un adulte en
amont nous résumons la différence
essentielle entre l'adulte et l'enfant à
partir de l'axiome suivant les adultes
sont des gens sérieux les enfants sont
des gens pas sérieux axiome que
corrobore magnifiquement le fameux
théorème de zavatta au plus qu'on est
moins petits au moins ce que les plus
grands l'épreuve du non sérieux de
l'enfant et du sérieux de l'adulte sont
innombrables en voici quelques unes
particulièrement évidente quand un
enfant veut s'amuser
il ramasse un bout de bois il dit poum
poum et son copain tombe par terre les
bras en croix en disant damned
s'il a appris le français dans tintin ou
argh
s'il a pris le français dans spirou puis
le copain se relève en disant on dirait
que j'en suis un autre puis il sort de
sa poche un cadeau bonux il le braque
sur l'ennemi en disant on dirait que
c'est mon rayon laser puis il ajoute biz
et ils enfant tombe en arrière en disant
vive la république s'il a appris le
français en lisant démocratie française
ce qui serait quand même mes talents
enfin les deux enfants repartent vers
jupiter
après avoir bu une grenadine en grimpant
sur le tabouret la cuisine pour pouvoir
attraper la bouteille sans se casser la
gueule
en revanche quand un adulte veut
s'amuser il ne ramasse pas un bout de
bois
pas con l'adulte il prend un fusil qui
fait poum poum pour de vrai et qui fait
pour de vrai des trous dans le ventre de
l'autre adultes qui tombe en arrière en
criant vive la france où vivent
l'allemagne ou vive le roi ou vive la
république
rayez les mentions inutiles à mon avis
elles le sont toutes
après quoi son sang coule pour devrait
tout autour de lui et il meurt doucement
dans la boue puis les autres adultes
ramasse plein d'atomes et il s'amuse de
plus en plus sérieusement à la fin il ya
deux camps et le chef du premier camp
dit à l'autre
la concentration de missiles anti
missiles sur votre territoire nous
contraint à renforcer notre sécurité en
construisant de nouveaux missiles anti
missiles antimissiles bisque bisque rage
et le chef du deuxième camp répond si la
concentration de missiles anti missiles
sur notre territoire vous contraint à
renforcer votre sécurité en construisant
de nouveaux missiles anti missiles
antimissiles nous n'hésiterons pas à
renforcer la nôtre en construisant de
nouveaux missiles anti missiles anti
missiles antimissiles la leyre la lettre
e et le chef du premier camp répond
c'est celui qui le dit qui y'est et la
terre explose une bonne fois pour toutes
donc les adultes sont plus sérieux que
les enfants par ailleurs la naïveté
grotesque des enfants fait peine à voir
surtout si l'on veut bien la comparer à
la maturité sereine qui caractérisent
généralement les adultes par exemple
l'enfant croit au père noël
l'adulte non l'adulte vote
autre exemple de la naïveté navrante des
enfants j'ai dans ma famille il ya un
neveu encore plus naïfs qu'un troupeau
de catholiques le dimanche à 11h ou
qu'un troupeau de protestants et juifs 1
ça m'est égal
c'est pas raciste un jour son père qui a
fait toute une histoire authentique
sinon je me permettrai pas d'emmerder le
tribunal avec ma vie privée
un jour son père qui a fait une partie
de ses études aux états unis lui annonce
la visite d'un de ses camarades
d'université américain qui s'appelait
donald white si j'ai bonne mémoire et
qui venait passer quelques jours en
france le move en question avait 6 ans à
l'époque déjà gorgés de fantasmes
télévisuelle et cinématiques ils
attendaient ce personnage mystérieux
américain à rixe avec la fébrilité
impatiente d'un lecanu et attendant le
retour de giscard d' un cégétiste
attendant un discours de marché et le
fameux donald arriva donc un dimanche
matin j'étais plutôt banal avec un blue
jeans moyens et un polo quelconque
et quand le donald en question son cadre
à dans la porte l'enfance plantes à face
à lui terrorisé puis bouleversé en
larmes il se jeta dans les bras de sa
mère en hurlant maman c'est pas un
canard enfin si l'on veut bien comparer
l'adulte à l'enfant d'un point de vue
purement poétique on s'apercevra là
encore de la supériorité de l'adulte
c'est un adulte qui écrit et le désir
s'accroît quand les faits ce recul
cédant polyeucte acte 1 scène 3 je
prends c'est encore un adulte qui a
écrit j'ai dit la vie et méchante les
com a répondu chante
c'était aux doors botrel mais c'est un
enfant qui a écrit naguère sur son
cahier d'écolier sous le titre sciences
naturelles
la vache à quatre pattes qui descendent
jusqu'à terre et le chat est pourvu
d'une queue qui s'arrête au bout d'un
moment
allez vive les enfants à vivre les
clones
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
etonnant non